hey what's going on it's bill burr and i
can't hear myself what the [ __ ] is wrong
with my
what's going on you know what it's
probably these radio shack headphones
what's going on here is that better
there we go
all right sorry how are you how's it
going it's the monday morning podcast
for november 28th
sorry 29th
2021 what's going on how
[Music]
how's it going
how's your holiday sh is your holiday
shopping magana
um do you have a nice thanksgiving
are you vaccinated just gonna keep
asking you annoying questions um
speaking of which my my whole game plan
of getting
the booster shot if you're into that
sort of thing not saying you got to be
you know
who gives i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
right so i'm going with it i'm going
with science
i'm sticking with you know when has
science ever done us wrong
um
you know that is that is the fly in the
ointment for everybody who's like pro
vaccinated they kind of [ __ ] ignored
the uh some of the times when they
missed the mark
um but i don't want to start that debate
but i just did that's always fun
um
anyway so my game plan was i was just
gonna walk into the
dingiest pharmacy i could find on black
friday
you know what i mean because i knew
their patrons would be outside of a
[ __ ] costco or a walmart trampling
each other and i figured they'd blow it
off
to go get the snoopy snow cone machine
for 40 off whatever the [ __ ] they're
going for right which is kind of good
though now that all the shopping's gone
online
that the trampling of people to death
after thanksgiving
day after thanksgiving too to get
trampled to death i mean the mess those
you know shout out
to the uh the first responders who got
to mop that mess up you know it's great
that that has ended unless you're
environmentalist i would think if you're
really a hardcore
environmentalist
you do not root for
people
and when you see a tragedy no matter how
high
the death toll is you're always sad that
it wasn't higher
you know
when you see how much we're you're just
out [ __ ] everything that could
potentially slow down the growth
the uncontrolled growth of us the sprawl
of humanity
jesus bill i thought you're gonna be the
holiday season sorry um
anyway so that was my game plan
and uh
it didn't happen
because uh i don't know i just ended up
getting sidetracked with some other [ __ ]
but i will tell you this it was
absolutely perfect flying weather
out here in l.a
barely any winds that's when i say winds
variable
visibility 10 statute miles the sky was
blue
wind had come through and blew all the
haze and everything out and old freckles
you know took it around the block
and i had
i had a blast
i just i had the best time
underrated flying for fun
as opposed to going for a rating after
offline all those
approaches and all that type of [ __ ]
even though i didn't get the rating i
learned so much and uh i'm still
studying my card so my test expires here
in a [ __ ] week or so but what i'm
gonna do is
you know i feel like i could go in and
pass it again immediately then i get
another two years and then i just gotta
get geared back up again when i have the
time but having said that i learned so
much you know i actually went out i
tracked a vor or whatever you know a
little thing on the ground shoots up the
radar signal for those of you not into
this [ __ ] i had a [ __ ] blast doing
that
and uh i also i've gotten
my uh my christmas shopping
is pretty much done i went out and i got
the big
you know now what are you gonna say gift
for everybody
you know
ho ho ho and shut your face shut your
face for another year
right
why would it be so hostile that you're
giving gifts um you know what it really
is it's the pressure
of like oh my god christmas is coming
have you done your christmas shopping
yet you know there's not a lot of stuff
left
that there's some sort of chip that they
need to be making and because of the
pandemic they haven't been making the
chips so there's got not going to be
enough bags to buy your wife you know
there's always that thing
you know
and i fall for it every time
the same way when i watch your horror
movie and they build up
and they go around the corner i always
think the person is going to be there i
always fall for that and then it's not
there and then they come back and then
there's the [ __ ] thing
the babadook thing right
so um
i got it all done and in the process
of figuring out like what i was going to
get my son
i mean i hooked him up i bought him the
classic tonka truck the one made out of
steel and then i got him an ac dc shirt
you know
you know why because i'm raising them
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
my daughter said to me yesterday we were
driving i was gonna go buy some eggnog
you know you're either an eggnog person
or you're not i [ __ ] love eggnog i
miss the booze in it but i'll [ __ ]
drink eggnog you put [ __ ] uh
what is that nutmeg in there i don't
give a [ __ ] i i [ __ ] love the stuff
i'm i'm like i can't go to sleep for
like three hours afterwards but i will
pour myself a tumbler of eggnog it'd sit
by a fire
everything but the pipe you know
so i was driving and uh
my daughter was like dad dad can i go
with you and i was like all right let's
go so she goes along with me and um
so i was like you want to hear some
christmas music and she goes yeah and
the only one i have is that dumb one
not dumb but i always i've always sung
it on the podcast you know
you know it's the holiday season dooby
dooby doo that whole [ __ ] thing so
i'm playing that
and she's loving it and everything was
awesome i gotta download some more
christmas music and i'm gonna take her
around playing the christmas music while
she uh looks at all the lights around
the house and stuff
on the houses i should say um
but um
i played that thing and as i was pulling
in you know to the grocery store she
said she said hey dad and i said what
and she said that uh
i actually wrote the quote down because
i always put her quotes in this [ __ ]
book here
uh jesus bill it would have been nice if
you had the thing ready right
that could have been a nice thing hang
on a second what do we got here
what did she say that's my set list
wait a minute did i lose it
ah whatever i remember what she said
anyways
she said hey dad i said what she said
christmas is way better than target
did i accidentally erase that
maybe i just sent it to my wife
i think i did hang on a second
oh [ __ ] somebody's in the neighborhood
yes
i'm doing my podcast just knock on the
front door
sorry
um
this whole [ __ ] podcast just went off
the rails because i'm not organized why
did i do this
here we go
now scrolling scrolling scrolling
scrolling
trying to find the thing thousand
[ __ ] pictures of kids
oh christmas is better than target yeah
that's right
because we go to target for her to air
quote test out the toys
and then which is you know it's always a
great thing because she's happy she's
psyched but then there's going to be the
inevitable inevitable meltdown when i
don't buy or anything you know cause
i'll tell you right now these damn kids
today they they think that they're gonna
[ __ ] get a gift every [ __ ] every
time they go in someplace
it's not how it works
okay
all right when i was a kid i'm doing
that [ __ ] when i was a kid you got one
pair of sneakers the beginning of the
[ __ ] school year and they bought them
like a size too big so you're floating
in them until like [ __ ]
the new year and then right as they
started to fit they look like you had
them for 10 years
then you didn't give a [ __ ] you just
kept wearing them
now these goddamn kids today they got to
have the right pair of [ __ ]
sneakers to match their their [ __ ]
belt on their outfit
it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable literally these little
[ __ ] herb tarlix walking around that
their [ __ ] belt has to match their
sneakers instead of their shoes
so um
anyway but i got all of that [ __ ]
out of the way i got my wife's big gift
all right
i got my son
i got my daughter's big gift
i am [ __ ] done so now all i'm gonna
do listen to this [ __ ]
this is how nice my december's gonna be
tonight
i'm [ __ ] coming out here
all right
out to the garage where i got everything
[ __ ] hit because everybody's so
goddamn nosey in my house i'm gonna come
out here and i'm wrapping the gifts in
november
i'm wrapping the gifts
i bought a [ __ ] christmas tree the
day after thanksgiving or maybe this
saturday i think this saturday right
after
and they had a thousand trees left and i
walked in the first one i saw was like
that tree is the [ __ ]
the guy goes you want to look at some
others and i'm like well i probably
should because my wife says i always
just go in and pick the first thing and
i walked three feet in and saw all this
green i'm like i'm not looking at all
that [ __ ] i'll take that one
[Music]
put it in my truck brought the [ __ ]
thing home
you know
put it up my wife was like oh my god
it's beautiful
that's it done
done i'm gonna have my gifts wrapped and
under the tree before the goddamn lights
are even on the thing all right they'll
relax
no because i know my life's going to get
a little busy here at the beginning part
of next year so i want to make sure that
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want to do
in december i can relax i don't have to
be freaking out did it arrive yet are
there any left can we get it in my size
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that i'm done i'm done with this
[ __ ] i'm done with this [ __ ]
like ohio state's dreams of winning a
championship are done that's how done
i am
with my christmas shopping you see what
i did there
out of respect
for ohio state university
i sing this song
hail to the victor's valiant hail to the
conquering heroes hail hail to michigan
the champions of the west
oh my god
what a [ __ ] game that was michigan
went out punched him in the [ __ ]
mouth finally and you got to give it up
to iowa state man i mean what a run nine
[ __ ] years
well really eight years but they gave
that [ __ ] spot to him you know but
we'll give it to him nine years
of just dominating the michigan
wolverines and all with the iowa state
fans [ __ ] babies about it
that was my favorite part watching those
[ __ ] crying
scarlet and gray [ __ ]
yeah
i was surprised that there wasn't
something trending the next day that
ohio state fans saying that they still
should be in the playoffs
um
so
congratulations
to uh um captain come back there finally
getting past
jim harbaugh
and uh osu made a lot of stupid [ __ ]
moves
bulletin board material let's hang a
hundred on them
stepping on michigan jerseys
and i didn't even get what harbaugh said
because you know some people are
standing on third base and they think
they they think they hit a triple
and i was thinking like what does that
mean they got
they got a walk and somebody hit a
double and knock them over like i was
just too stuck in baseball
and one of my buddies was like no this
guy inherited this team
and he's acting like he was the guy that
got him there so i was like oh [ __ ]
that's like some [ __ ]
you know head coach real housewife [ __ ]
um
but i was so psyched uh it was great to
see the michigan fans i mean it's not
good for a rivalry if you know you got
to have a little back and forth
um or it becomes just
like well the red sox used to be where
we just never won
so it just you kind of showed up just to
see the train wreck and also to be like
could this be the year
um
yeah i guess you either want it to be
that way or have it go back and forth
but um
one of the great rivalries
in all of sports and i used to think the
red sox yankees was a big thing until
one time i watched one of those espn 60
for 60s at 30 for 30s on the michigan
ohio state rivalry and i was like [ __ ]
okay
this this is a little bigger than what
i've been watching so um you know i'm
just busting ohio state's balls it's a
great [ __ ] program
with great fans and all that type of
[ __ ] and i know not all of them whine
about making the [ __ ] playoffs every
year but uh just the ones i know do
[Laughter]
so congratulations to the michigan
wolverines and how about your new
england patriots
you [ __ ] new england point you want
six in a row now something like that
unbelievable
unbelievable and how about a shout out
to whoever the guy was that was doing
color
patriots first titans he was driving me
up the wall
patriots kept driving down in in you
know getting field goals instead of
touchdowns and this guy just he couldn't
blow the titans enough i mean the trains
got to be happy they're going to be
happy with where they're at you know
they're you know they're not giving up
touchdowns you only gave a field goal
you know a lot of people didn't say
they'd even be in this game who said
that it was a five and a half point
spread let's not make it seem like it
was double digit favorites here
i also love because one of my buddies
says field goals are for losers
and we kicked five of them to the tune
of 15 points which if you're keeping
score at home is two touchdowns with a
two-point conversion
field goals are not for losers unless
you're going to say the great paul brown
was wrong
unless you're going to tell me you had a
viditari didn't happen and three of our
super bowl trophies aren't because of
his [ __ ] right foot
um
sorry let me turn this down here i think
i'm [ __ ] redlining here um anyway
just a great
great victory i mean i'm not gonna lie
to you our run defense looks a little
suspect
um
but i also know we have bill belichick
so he's gonna fix whatever that problem
is
and by the way how deep are the titans
at the running back position
do you think you know derek henry goes
down like that's going to be at the end
of it
and then they got like it's like he was
like an atom that split and they had
like these two other guys just
running all over us and the guy just
kept going you know like the color guy
you know they're doing great they're
hanging out
we force the fumble doesn't say anything
we go down and then we have to kick a
field goal again not to mention we had a
touchdown the only thing i could say
that mac jones the one mistake he made
he had a guy wide open for a touchdown
other than that the throws this kid was
making for that first touchdown in the
[ __ ] corner of the end zone
he dropped it in there dare i say like
russell wilson
um
anyway it was a great win and uh mike
frable is a [ __ ] great coach too by
the way
he just has an injured team and uh
i wonder does does he get
does bill belichick because he coached
him as a player
is rabel part of belichick's coaching
tree does anybody know how that works or
do you then retire and then whoever you
coach with
begins your coaching treat that's
probably how it works i have no idea
but um patriots all of a sudden after
starting out two and four are now eight
in four
um
two big tests coming up against buffalo
i feel like buffalo woke up from
whatever the [ __ ] they were doing
destroying the saints but the saints
also were without their uh you know drew
brees retired and then jameis winston uh
unfortunately
ruptured his acl i believe so
but i guess you could say buffalo did
what they were supposed to do
with the team you know essentially with
whoever would have been their third
string quarterback last year
um
but that was a big test coming up i
watched the celtic spurs see this is
what happens when you get your [ __ ]
christmas shopping and everything done
done
i did my ac dc shopping today
right i bought a back and black album i
got a t-shirt for my son
and then i got i got a i got a power
rage t-shirt for one of my buddies
um
so i was just able to watch all the
games you know i missed the bruins when
we lost to uh
we lose with us to the rangers and i
think they're playing tonight too but i
watch celtic spurs
jesus christ um
we just came out flat and they they came
out flying
it took us the whole game to get caught
up as perkins said and then when the
spurs had that last run we were freaking
out of gas but whatever i enjoyed all of
that i went on some great hikes so i
kind of leveled out and maybe gained a
couple of pounds
got on the scale i'm 183 i've been
really just having a hard time [ __ ]
dropping
this weight dude just i've been on the
road too much but this week i'm gonna
hit it hard
like i've been saying since july
when i was 189 i'm 183 i have lost six
pounds
but i just been see-sawing but now i
just gotta focus this five fridays
in december
i'm having five weigh-ins
and i'm hoping to drop a couple of
pounds each week which would get me down
to buck 73 and all of a sudden my suits
would fit me again
all right
no one wants to see fat freckles i love
him when uh
oh it's a scalabrine is that his name
the guy who does the celtics
commentating i only listen to him every
time i [ __ ] love that guy i love when
he does the
the haircut club commercials
talking about his red locks he's like do
people want to see him
[Music]
uh
scalab yeah scalabrine man i [ __ ]
love that guy
you know um
you know obviously it was horrible that
tommy heinsohn passed but you know
this kid came in and just really is
doing a hell of a job filling that guy's
shoes
uh really knows the game
and he's just enough of a homer
that uh it you know i feel like it's a
nice nod
to tommy heinz i mean nobody can replace
that guy that guy was when he used to
get on the refs that was my
that was my favorite thing ever
but
um anyway
yeah so i had an awesome thanksgiving i
hope you guys did too
uh played some drums i hung out with my
kids
my son is a maniac
he like headbutts the couch
throws himself all around he's just
a lunatic
like he literally has me putting my arms
up he comes in like
you ever see like when uh
when like gorillas run at something and
they want to hit it they bring both
their arms up like behind their head and
then they come slamming down that's what
he does
he comes running at me
and uh he really can get going
and sometimes i'm just sitting there
watching tv and i don't see it coming
and it gives me a nice little shot to
the stomach end of the chest i'm like
jesus
christ and then my daughter thinks it's
hilarious if i'm laying down on the
floor and i'm not looking
she leaps up in the air and does hulk
hogan's finishing move on my stomach
and you know i usually you know
obviously i see that coming but one time
i was laying on the floor and i had a
pillow or a sweatshirt
over my eyes we have this horrible track
lighting
in this room right
so i just had it over my eyes because i
was tired and i was just totally relaxed
and she leapt up in the air and landed
on my stomach when it was totally
totally relaxed
uh
i thought i was gonna have to go to the
hospital i said buddy you can't you
can't do that
you can't treat me like a beanbag even
though i'm shaped like one right now um
what else if i did a couple of sets
i took a drum lesson which is always
great
and then i discovered this drummer
uh sarah thorough
t-h-a-w-e-r
and um
i think she's an indian drummer i always
the indian drummers are [ __ ] amazing
because they
have that thing where they first of all
the crazy time signatures that they play
in but then they also do this thing
where when they teach them drums they
have to sing the fill
i think before they play it or something
like that that's part of their teaching
and i think that that's why
there's such beasts because um
all the musicians i've ever met that are
playing on another level like totally
present and just playing this
other worldly [ __ ]
are able to
hear an idea and then immediately
execute it
and i think that's from years of just
singing
something and then figuring out how to
play it and then what happens is the gap
between those two of those
closes to the point that you can do it
in real time
um like i was talking to this bass
player the other day and she was telling
me that uh
she would get into a zone
and literally not even know what she was
playing and then there'd be some sort of
movement in the crowd
that would distract her and then she'd
have like a half a second panic of like
oh [ __ ] where are we in the song but she
was able to recover
but like um
i don't know
that's that kind of thing that just
that's why
musicians amaze me
their ability to like learn how to speak
again when you perform at that level i
would say
uh as opposed to just sitting down
playing a bunch of licks over and over
and over again to actually be like
hearing somebody play something
feel something
within you and then communicate it
through whatever instrument you're
playing in real time in any tempo is
[ __ ] insane
um so
all right with that
let's do some of the reads here for this
week oh look who it is everybody it's
simply safe
you know
if you've ever wanted to make your home
feel safer
there is no better time than now this
week my friends
my old buddy said simply say for giving
my listeners early access to their all
uh to all their black friday's deals
50 off their award-winning home security
i love simply safe because it has
everything you need to make your home
safe indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send help the instant
you need it simply safe was even named
best home security system of 2021 by u.s
news and world report you can easily
customize a system for your online your
home online in minutes and even get a
free custom recommendations from simply
safe these are simply safe's biggest
discounts of the year you can get a
complete home security system starting
at just over 100
there are no long-term contracts or
commitments it's really it's a really
easy way to start feeling a bit more
peace of mind take advantage of simply
safe
simply saves early black friday deals
and get fifty percent off your new home
security system by visiting simply
safe.com
again that's simplysafe.com
s-i-n-p-l-i-s-a-f-e dot com
f-e dot com sorry for 50 off your entire
system
okay oh not to bum you guys out
but i tell you about those kittens those
stray kittens that just showed up in my
yard
this has a potentially sad ending
you know they were hanging around we
couldn't get them to come in they
wouldn't trust us
they would just take off whatever so
we're leaving food and we're trying to
build their trust
and uh and i thought i was about a day
away from getting them inside i was
going to put them in a crate and i
somebody told me about somebody
you know
or they had like a no kill thing or
whatever and uh
i don't know man they just haven't been
here in a couple of days and i got a bad
feeling i got a bad feeling about it
really bummed me out
i heard some sort of commotion
that sounded like a cat and coyotes come
down and they were [ __ ] kittens and
they didn't know to not like make noise
but they were like grown up enough where
they were fast as [ __ ]
and i couldn't get near him and i was
trying to [ __ ]
get him into the damn house and uh
it just uh yeah i haven't seen him in
like three days but my wife's going like
well who knows maybe somebody else got
him to come inside
it's like i don't know man once we
started feeding them they were hanging
around our yard you know so
i don't know
i think they got killed everybody
because at one night i heard
a [ __ ] crazy thing
and uh they weren't making a lot of
noise like the first time i heard them
they didn't know enough to not like be
meowing really loudly at night and i was
like you know we got coyotes we got
raccoons
you know we got other [ __ ] cats just
so many things out there i don't know
so if anybody has any suggestions on how
to
get cats to like they just
you know every time you get like close
they would just [ __ ] take off and
then i would sit there and not do
anything
and just have some salmon nearby
but uh
they just wouldn't take it and then
you'd leave and then they come and they
grab it and they'd run away with it
so
uh i don't know so bummed me out so i
figured i'd tell you guys about it i
don't know what was the purpose of that
bum you guys out i mean that's what
happened this week
no [ __ ] cats man
it was like a zombie movie they were out
there every every night i was just
seeing but you guys made it you made it
all right come on inside come inside
come on
they were just like ah we don't know you
buddy
me a favor set down the fish and slowly
[ __ ] walk away that was that was
their deal all right best man's speech
here people
let's do a little thing here uh best man
speech bomb oh no bill
i worked a wedding this weekend
the best man did one of your bits during
his speech poorly
oh no
he opened up with i'm borrowing this bit
from bill burr
and that was the best part of the speech
what what [ __ ] bit did he do
hey shout out to whoever that best man
was you know
i bomb all the time too so it happens
oh brother
oh jesus
i'm trying to think of a bit that you
could of mine that you could do at a
wedding that uh
he didn't do the gold digging [ __ ] did
he
oh
jesus
hey you know what
that was probably the first time he's
been the best man hopefully not the last
you know
he threw a pick six you know what
happens
you go up there as long as his heart was
in the right place you know i i don't
think it's
[Music]
dude when you i want to hear more
speeches i'm more people talking about
that when you bomb as a [ __ ] best man
and then you got literally you got the
whole [ __ ] wedding of people just
looking at you i mean you got to go hit
the bar whether it's open
an open bar or a pay bar you got to go
hit that thing you got to hit it [ __ ]
hard man
um
anyway let's uh
let's plow ahead here all right this
person writes in bill is a popular name
yeah i was looking up to see uh
all the names i grew up with
like i was just thinking man they're
like really dying off like i have not
met like a little mike or a little steve
joe
jason
was a big name jason was a big name when
i was growing up lot of jason's steve's
mike's
dave david was a big one dave
what's going on dude bob's bills toms
murray no no murray um
this person is claiming that bill is a
popular name
dear billy [ __ ] balls
i wanted to let you know that your name
isn't so rare these days i have a
a pit mix mutt [ __ ] with a long nipple
and her name is foxy
and i have a rottweiler named jocko
after jaco pastorius the bass player
i move out to the country during the
pandemic to get the [ __ ] away from the
cove idiots
and i was outside one night hanging with
the dogs and heard a [ __ ]
meow cry
i grabbed a flashlight and found a tiny
one-pound kitten alone and brought him
inside how the [ __ ] did you do that it
must have been just
i must suck at it i'm a dog person he's
now best friend with both dogs and i
named him bill because your podcast
seriously saved my flaccid ass
from all of the [ __ ] that's on the news
and seems to get worse
wait so you're telling me
that my name isn't dying you just named
a cat you named a kitten bill
um when i took bill per oh jesus
to get his nuts snipped at the vet there
was a puppy getting his balls snipped
with the name bill as well
well i think that that's basically how a
name starts to die off it's you know it
starts with people people like it
and then you [ __ ] then it's people
stop naming people af that name they
start naming pets that name
um
anyway he said there was a puppy getting
his ball snipped with the name bill as
well i was thinking to
get neutrals for the cat
but going to wait until they're one of
your sponsors
what is that they fill the ball bag back
up again with [ __ ]
fake balls
this kitten is hilarious and will sneak
treats to my rottweiler
he has a [ __ ] meow when he wants
something and is super cute we even took
ballis billy purr
down to st louis when you played at the
fox theater you were hilarious and my
cheeks were hurting from laughing so
much sorry to hear about cleo losing a
dog is brutal you're the best to go [ __ ]
yourself crazy [ __ ] lady now wait a
second
nudicals
like who are you doing that for the dog
doesn't give a [ __ ]
dog probably wanted to keep its balls
after that
nudicles
testicular implantations for pets are
you [ __ ] kidding me
wow
for over a quarter of a century cti
corporation has provided caring pet
owners and progressive veterinarians
worldwide with safe and effective and
revolutionary pet innovations
it began in 1995 with the patented
neuticles
testicular i would love to see this get
pitched on shark tank testicular
implantations for pets helping
neuter hesitant pet owners overcome the
trauma of altering and allowing their
beloved pet to retain its natural look
and self-esteem
the dog gets self-esteem out of having
its balls taken replaced by fake balls
that's all for the owner
that is some dumb ass [ __ ] and i can
guarantee you that will never be
advertised on the podcast
hey it's nudicles everybody
hit me granted i just kind of talked
about him
that is nuts
okay the shot that killed jfk oh jesus i
i drew him out of the woodwork
hi bill love your shows and all your
podcasts always agree with you and yeah
i'm a 67 year old woman and i love the
way you come up with your amazing advice
for people mainly the males who write in
so quickly
anyway if you want to know who killed
jfk look up mortal error on wikipedia
about the book mortal error the shot
that killed jfk
by bonner
meninger
outlining the the theory by
sharpshooter gunsmith and ballistics
expert howard donahue
that is
that a secret service agent in the limbo
behind jfk accidentally fired the shot
that killed kennedy after he'd been shot
in the neck by oswalt
i haven't read the book but the talk
the taco the doc was totally convincing
love to you and your family wait a
minute
you're telling me some secret service
guy pulled his gun out and [ __ ] himself
and accidentally shot him in the what
now that's a brand new one
hang on a second
jfk
fatal shot
secret
service agent here we go this will get
me on a [ __ ] watch list
mortal error
conducting his own investigation donahue
decided that the bullet that struck
kennedy in the head and in fact been
fired by united states secret service
agent
george warren hickey jr now you're gonna
put his [ __ ] name out there like
you can't even prove it
okay mortal error
is a 1992 non-fiction book by bonner
meninger
outlining a theory by sharpshooter oh
this person just sort of copied and
pasted this
maringer is also the author of and hell
followed with it life and death in a
kansas tornado
which won kansas's note notable book
award
in 2011.
all right that's interesting
kansas's notable book award all right
i'm going to not do the easy joke there
donahue first became interested in the
story of the assassination of john f
kennedy after participating in a
recreation of the shooting
as one of 11 invited marksmen and
sharpshooters he demonstrated that it
would have been
been possible for lee harvey oswald to
have fired three shots in the time
specified by the warren commission and
was the only one of
the eleven
to better the 5.6 window
however the experience highlighted
to donahue other concerns regarding the
warren report and in particular the fact
that the testimony of the ballistics
expert seems to have been completely
omitted
from the commission's ev i've already
just zoned out i don't know what i'm
reading
now he believes ottawa's second shot
through kennedy's neck may have been
already critically wounded the president
by the time the third shot was fired
donahue was encouraged in his
investigations
by ralph reppert
uh reporter of the baltimore sun 77
ripper published donnie usterian two
articles which appeared may 1st
donny reconstructed the trajectories of
the shot that struck kennedy and
governor conley supported the single
bullet theory for a second shot donnie
decided that the impossible trajectory
suggested the warren commission was only
necessary because there was an error
oh my god all right this is why you're
never going to solve it i i can't
[ __ ] read all of that all right
so he's saying that somebody so he took
the gun out
because i've heard you know cops back in
the day when they had their sick shooter
rookies the first time they had to pull
their gun out in a gunfight by the time
they brought it up level they were empty
they were so freaking out like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] they like they were pulling it out
shooting at the ground and bringing it
up
click click click click
um
oh that's interesting that's an
interesting theory
i have no idea sounds pretty good to me
man
thanks for solving it you heard it here
uh 44 years after the book came out all
right first order as a dictator hey bill
long time fan i'm too high right now to
come up with some
alliterations
like all these other smart [ __ ] so i'll
just get right to the point there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with mentally tapping out just
being like you know what
i know my limitations i'm not good at
that [ __ ] all right if you were a
dictator
like kim jong-un
or adolf hitler
at the beginning of their reign what
would be the first bill or act you would
do i've been wondering what your
response would be to this as this idea
popped up in my head
multiple times as i drive through
atlanta atlanta traffic
like if i was a dictator i would get rid
of all the cars in the country every
single one i don't care how far your job
is i don't care if you have to get your
kids or even if your wife is pregnant
you better walk or take a [ __ ] horse
because i'd be the only one with the car
god i [ __ ] hate atlantic traffic
atlanta traffic
they just can't drive yeah atlanta will
do that to you
um
all right well now that you went real
selfish do i have to go selfish too
if i was a dictator
uh nfl championships would count
um it wouldn't start with the super bowl
nfl championships would count
that would be the first thing that would
be one it would be a three-pronged
attack so that's handles sports
um
i don't know such a [ __ ] big one like
what the [ __ ] would i do
i have to do something
i would
give massive massive massive tax breaks
to people
for not having kids
and an even bigger tax break if you
didn't have a kid and you adopted
instead
and then my goal would be
to get the world population but i'd only
be running a country i just see it our
country's population
well if you're a dictator i could then
tell the banks
well you can never get out from under
the banks even if you're a dictator
i would have the
i would have the [ __ ]
my militia
take out the bankers
we'd start all over again
on a new currency and every but nobody
owed any money
everything is forgiven
and everybody you come back in with the
new currency which i don't understand
why they can't do this if everybody just
agrees to it all right
everybody just comes back in
whatever you have in the bank is what
you still have in the bank except you
don't [ __ ] know anybody anything
all right
i would then have one four day weekend
every single month
not just thanksgiving there'd be a four
day weekend every single month
okay and you're thinking well why are
you doing that bill that's gonna make
you know the economy tank i don't give a
[ __ ]
because the people who'll eventually
want to rise up against me i think it's
going to take a long time he's a good
[ __ ] man he gives you a free [ __ ]
thanksgiving weekend
11 11 extra thanksgiving weekends
you know i would do a day i do away with
dress down fridays
i think that was the beginning
of uh
the end of a lot of like respectful ways
that people do business
the hostile way now i would do away now
another thing too that uh you know
corporations would have to go back to
answering their [ __ ] phones
and not be like i'm sorry that's not an
option main menu
you know and just send you back to that
first one again [ __ ] that
i'd get rid of that oh geez i'm on i'm
on a [ __ ] roll now
um
i don't know then i would just do a
bunch of things for like admissions get
everybody's emissions down not saying
you have to go to electric cars or solar
panels just whatever we needed to do
and uh really educate people on uh
consumption and all that type of stuff
and what we're doing to the environment
and then uh
then you'd have to deal with how we get
along with each other
i don't know i would just set up like
try to set up some things that made
people want to help out other people
educate other people that weren't doing
as well
you kind of have to do that and then
they have to be some sort of test that
you know just because you're poor
doesn't mean you're
you know you're just automatically not a
[ __ ]
so you got to make sure that if you're
going to help out less fortunate people
they're actually worthy of it because
just like not all rich people are
[ __ ]
you know not all poor people are saints
so
you kind of weed out
i don't know how the [ __ ] you would do
that
yeah that's a big one but if i just had
to do one
that the one thing that i would do i
would try to do what some sort of
sweeping change that would [ __ ] stop
this
uh
you know global warming horseshit i
would try to do that just so you know
you see kids you're like what kind of
world are they gonna have
geez this has been an oddly like
depressing one dead kittens [ __ ]
global warming and [ __ ]
um
dilemma
you know that's one thing dictators
always [ __ ] up man
they don't give a they don't give back
enough
you know what i mean i don't know why
they always try to just hoard everything
to themselves it just
builds resentment
you know didn't they learn anything
it's like [ __ ]
bread circus and [ __ ] that they used to
do when they could feel people starting
to get hostile
you know
give them a four day weekend why can't
we have a four day weekend
all it is is just an extra two days off
every month
you know
let me ask you this
what if like one week
work week every month you just had to go
hard
on monday tuesday wednesday
all right
you don't have to put in 48
40 hours
you put in three 13-hour days
and they didn't have to pay your time
and a half either
right
so they would get 39 hours out of you
they'd also have you nice and fresh on
monday because you get a four day
[ __ ] weekend
i mean what if that's what what it was
what if i did that what if there was 52
three-day weeks
a year that you worked right
but every weekend you had a you worked
three days and then you had four days
off
every [ __ ] week
but you just had to go hard monday
tuesday wednesday
that's it
there's no overtime
you just had to [ __ ]
you had to show up ready to you got to
show up ready to play monday tuesday
wednesday and then you get thursday
friday saturday sunday off
you know what would happen
people would become raging alcoholics
they would put on [ __ ]
oh my god how many [ __ ] pounds would
you put on
yeah that'd be some i don't know
see it always starts with a small idea
then it gets out of control let's dial
it back once
a
month you go hard for three days and
then you get a four day [ __ ] weekend
that's it
that's it and you get [ __ ] two in in
in november
and then that becomes
everybody's favorite month
and then i would i would
black history month gets moved to march
so they get 31 days
which is more than 30
and 2 more than 29 or 28 and then you
make up all those days you [ __ ] them
out of since you brought that up there
you go this is some basic ones
you know
and if you go to a stadium
an opposing team stadium with the other
team's jersey on
and you're acting like a [ __ ] jerk
off
um
there should there should just be
somebody
like specific for security just for that
person
just for that person so the person
doesn't get hurt they are just removed
okay but they have to do something the
hometown fans can't just be mad because
he's wearing the other jersey you're not
allowed to attack the person to hurt him
they're just removed
removed from the situation
and how they are removed is a helicopter
comes in hovers over the [ __ ] stadium
drops a line down the person is put into
some sort of like shrink wrap
and then is hoisted up
and brought out like like a log
um all right dilemma dear bill would you
rather be a simple nerd living on a
small budget enjoying his life of board
games
lord of the ring and rings and nerd
books
uh in a one-bedroom apartment in a small
town and a simple job at the grocery
store with no excitement but complete
comfort and peace i mean that sounds
amazing
simple dinners on a tv tray and the
occasional dessert from the bakery
you're not in shape but you're not obese
you're unknown to the public
you have a cousin with the family you
see on
holidays but that's it i have no family
uh yeah [ __ ] that
or
be famous
single a celebrity and [ __ ] models
except there's a long-standing rumor
going around that you beat the [ __ ]
out of your ex-girlfriend's dog
but the cops let you off cause you're
famous
well that's easy yeah i can handle that
i never hit that dog i love dogs
you could easily do that you just show
yourself out with all your rescue dogs
anyway now you certainly didn't
but that's the rumor okay so i certainly
didn't beat the dog it's supported by
lots of evidence
and you are commonly known as the guy
who kicked the dog the woman you [ __ ]
don't seem to mind the rumor
and you put off that they will [ __ ] you
anyway despite that this
that they don't know it's not true
people look at you funny in public
is it because they believe the rumor or
that they know you're famous and like
your work your life is a house of cards
which do you
choose well you know what you should
have had me have a family in the first
one
the fact that i don't have a family
i'm not gonna be that [ __ ]
pudgy uncle who never got his [ __ ]
together
you know some [ __ ] what of a job
bag and gross she's uh but he's happy
now i'm out i'm gonna [ __ ] yeah i'll
be the bad boy that maybe kick the dog
who [ __ ] models i would choose that
i would choose that emptiness over the
previous emptiness
even though you said i was happy and at
peace
i guess i got to put that in there
with no excitement but complete comfort
and peace but i'm at peace
if you could somehow rewire me in that
first one that i could be in complete
comfort and peace i would absolutely
accept that one
without a [ __ ] doubt
um
as opposed to the other one where there
was no peace
and [ __ ] models and all of that i
would think that that would get sad
quickly
if you were raised right
you know if you're in your 20s
everything is great 30s you're kind of
like what am i doing
40s it's like jesus
jesus
what am i doing
what am i doing why are they here
because the older the bigger the age gap
gets the more concerned you have to be
with like how [ __ ] up is this person
that not only they banged me they now
want to have a relationship with me like
you got to be thinking that you're
getting damaged good
you know
wrapped up in a beautiful package
um
yeah i wouldn't do that i would take uh
yeah i think i would take the first one
as long as i was at peace i'm at peace
with the fact that i'm a [ __ ] nerd i
don't get to watch sports
or is this me
and i just have to play the role of some
guy that wants to play board games
um
i can i'll put myself in both of those
me in both those situations i would go
out of my [ __ ] mind if i was in the
first one if i was living alone the
amount i already talked to myself if i
had nobody else i just had these [ __ ]
board games and an occasional dessert
and then i have to swing by a family
members oh yeah [ __ ] that i would uh i
would be slowly drinking myself to death
probably rapidly at that point and then
i also got the regular job so i'm not
even drinking good booze so i imagine i
would be mixing the booze
you know
with some
cola
right so that's the double whammy
um
yeah
i think i would choose yeah i would
choose the uh the cliched
cliched hollywood [ __ ] experience
you know
showing up with [ __ ]
cocaine boogers in my nose
oh god dude that's a that's a bad
dilemma neither one of those were happy
i don't like that
you guys there was there was no [ __ ]
i guess what's that that's why they call
it a dilemma everybody
um
i got a dilemma it's ten or five and the
sun's already
almost gone down and i still gotta go
out and [ __ ] do my little uh my
little hikey hike here which i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna do it beefcake beefcake it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen i found
this new park i'm not going into it now
because it closes at sunset
allegedly and um
that's when the fun begins honey
um
i'm gonna go uh
i don't know i'll take a walk around the
neighborhood that's what i'm gonna do
by the way i went into a [ __ ] record
store today i could not believe the
amount of young people the place was
[ __ ] packed
and the amount of young people that were
in there was insane and i was going
through you know and i was trying to buy
these classic albums from my daughter
and uh
you know
of course i had ac dc back in black but
a few others like joan jett i love rock
and roll
they didn't have that one aerosmith's
greatest hits they didn't have that one
uh but then i had to think like well
wait a minute you know
some odd years of music have gone by
at least with those uh the ac dc and the
aerosmith since
these albums came out so i mean there is
a finite amount of [ __ ] room
um
in there but like
i was i don't know i was kind of bummed
and i was like all right well maybe i
can at least get the toys in the attic
album because the song she likes is walk
this way which she of course is
convinced
that the lyrics are for kids play
and i've tried to correct her and i just
decided i'd let her figure it out for
herself
because you know that song you can have
a lot of different interpretations and
uh her interpretations of four kids play
four kids play
for kids play you know what and when
she's brilliant enough to say that
christmas is better than target
um
who am i to argue all right well that's
the podcast everybody old twinkle toes
he's got to work off all the [ __ ]
stuffing that he stuffed himself with i
hope you guys had a wonderful weekend
once again congratulations
to the university of michigan football
team we bow to no one congratulations on
your big win ohio state unbelievable run
you knew you weren't gonna win forever
but [ __ ] you know let's see can
michigan win nine in a row who knows we
shall see
um but it's very critical right now
because
if michigan beats you again next year
okay and your coach who built the thing
is now down in jacksonville hanging out
on the hooters
um
urban meyer like all of a sudden these
young kids might want to start instead
of going to ohio state if they're going
to go big ten they go michigan
and then what happens
a whole lot of whining from the other
side is what i'm thinking so
um
and bill belichick once again once again
all these [ __ ] idiots when tom brady
and the buccaneers won it last year
we're going like does that mean tom was
really well bill belichick
he's doing it again
all right
he's on his way again to building and
yet another championship team and he's
not going to stop until the new england
patriots win number seven and i i have
every belief in the world that it's
going to happen there you go you heard
it here first on the [ __ ] monday
morning podcast all right that's the
monday morning
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check in
on you on thursday
and uh thank you to everyone who came
out to supernova this weekend all right
i'll see you